[Music]
and we greet you in the name of our Lord
and Savior Jesus Christ and welcome you
to I'd like to know our Bible question
and answer program here at SumTV. My
name is CA Murray. To my left, Pastor
David Salazar, general manager of our
Latino channel. to my right, Pastor
Stephen Boore, founder and president of
this ministry. Gentlemen, always good to
study the word of God with you.
>> Amen.
>> And always we we like to encourage you
to write your questions to us because
gives us a chance to answer your
questions and to study the word of God.
Something we covet and we like to do.
Write to us at tvsumtv.
There it is on your screen. TV tvsum
suum as in marytv.org.
o rg that gets your questions into our
rather long and impressive list and we
make you the promise that we will answer
them if an answer indeed can be found
from the word of God. We will try to
give you that answer and do do
difference uh to do just that. You will
notice on this program we don't we don't
rush through. It's not quantity that
we're we're trying to get done here.
It's quality. We you send your question,
we want to give you a quality answer
from the word of God. You deserve that.
and the kingdom of God deserves that.
And that's what we humbly try to do. I'm
going to ask Pastor Salazar if you would
ask God's blessing on us and then we
will launch out in today's program.
>> Let us pray.
Heavenly Father, we thank you once again
for allowing us to be able to
communicate with you to be able to come
to the throne of grace and the source of
all wisdom which is you and the
influence of the Holy Spirit which can
allow us to understand and receive the
knowledge of what you have written in
your word. We ask humbly that you will
allow us to be used by you and that the
answers that we may give may not be our
answers, may not be our own words, but
may be your words in accordance to your
will. We thank you for your blessing in
Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen. And amen. Now I'm going to read uh
question number 73 from Ry Rhy ne
um and then we can we can discuss it and
and give our response. From your
previous lectures I came to understand
for the first time that the 24 elders
are representatives of unfallen worlds
atoms of their rep representative
planets. I am failing to reconcile uh
the fact that God could have created
only 24 worlds considering the vastness
of the universe. Can I get more clarity
on whether the 24 elders are
representatives of only 24 literal
worlds or if the number 24 is just a
symbolic number representing numerous
unfallen worlds and their
representatives? Pastor, I think you had
a response to this.
Okay, first of all, I want to recommend
uh study notes that I wrote several
years ago. I'll show you the cover. It's
uh on the 24 elders. That's the title,
24 elders.
And um basically I would suggest to um
to Ryan
if he would uh go online and get a copy
of this particular group of study notes.
Uh because in order to answer this
question uh you have to actually look at
the entire trajectory of the 24 elders
in scripture. Mhm.
>> And um there are six presentations in
this uh in this document and I would
recommend that Ryan read uh chapter
number six. Um let me just go first of
all to Isaiah chapter 24
which is describing the second coming of
Christ
>> and the desolation of the earth. Mhm.
>> And uh and let's just go to uh Isaiah
chapter 24
>> and begin at verse 18 where the second
coming is being described and the
desolation of the earth. So sell us out.
>> Yes. I read there Isaiah 24:18.
And it shall be that he who flees from
the noise of the fear shall fall into
the pit, and he who comes up from the
midst of the pit shall be caught in the
snare. For the windows from the on high
are open, and the foundations of the
earth are shaken. The earth is violently
broken. The earth is split open. The
earth is shaken exceededly. The earth
shall reel to and for like a drunkard, a
drunkard, and shall totter like a hut.
Its transgression shall be heavy upon
it, and it will fall and not rise again.
>> Okay, let's stop there just for a
moment. Clearly, it's describing the
second coming of Christ and the
desolation of the earth.
>> Correct?
>> Um, and then it in verse 21, it's going
to speak about something that happens in
that day. In other words, when when this
these events take place, the second
coming, something's going to happen in
verse 21. So, read verse 21.
>> It shall come to pass in that day that
the Lord will punish on high the host of
exalted ones and on the earth the kings
of the earth.
>> Okay, let's stop there for a moment.
>> So, at the second coming, it says that
God is going to punish on high the host
of the exalted ones.
>> Those are Satan and his angels.
>> Correct. And then it also says on earth
the kings of the earth. If you go to
Revelation 19, it says that the kings of
the earth are punished when Jesus comes
on the white horse.
>> Correct.
>> Okay. So notice it says that they that
God is going to punish them at the
second coming.
>> Right?
>> But that's not the end.
>> Notice verse 22.
>> They will be gathered together
as prisoners are gathered in the pit and
will be shut up in the prison. After
many days they will be punished.
>> Okay. Okay, now wait a minute. Weren't
they punished already?
>> It says it says verse 21. Yeah. That at
the second coming they're punished. And
then here it says after many days
they're going to be punished. So their
punishment has two stages.
>> Correct.
>> So what is the what is this referring to
when it says they're gathered together
as prisoners and they're set up in
prison? Well, Revelation 20 says that
Satan, right,
>> is cast into prison and the wicked,
they're in the prison of the grave,
>> correct?
>> For thousand years. And then
>> what are the many days? After the many
days, they're going to be punished.
That's a thousand years.
>> Correct. Thousand years.
>> But then what I want to focus on is
verse 23, which takes place after the
many days.
>> Correct. And it reads there, then the
moon will be disgraced and the sun
ashamed, for the Lord of hosts will
reign on Mount Zion and in Jerusalem and
before his elders gloriously.
So what does God have? He has elders.
>> Elders. Yes.
>> And what is he going to do?
>> Reign over them.
>> He's going to reign over his elders.
>> Now, who will these elders be? Well,
there's no doubt whatsoever that the
elders, it has to do with with
individuals of experience, right?
>> Uh represent the members of the heavenly
council of the worlds that never sinned.
Just read the last three pages of Desire
of Ages
>> where Ellen White clearly identifies the
the elders as the representatives of the
worlds that never sinned. Um the number
24 that is used there is actually a
symbolic number. It's like all the other
numbers in the book of Revelation except
for the thousand years.
>> Yeah.
>> And we've dealt with the thousand years
before. But you know all the numbers in
the book of revelation with the
exception of the thousand years which
are literal um are symbolic numbers. So
the number 24 doesn't mean that there's
only 24 worlds. The number 24 is related
to the service of the priest in the
sanctuary.
>> Right?
>> Basically they serve for 24
weeks twice a year.
>> In other days they serve the needs of
the congregation.
>> Right? Um and so the 24 elders are those
who administrate the universe of God.
>> Let me just mention here the functions
of the elders in the New Testament. The
functions of of the elders in the
church.
>> Um uh the elders in the church are
rulers.
Uh I can just maybe read some uh
quotations here. It says, "Let the
elders who rule
well be accounted worthy of double
honor." So, they're rulers.
>> And there's more quotations. Uh, it says
u uh the bishop or overseer must be one
who rules over his house.
>> So, in other words, the elders are
rulers. They are also representatives.
>> Yes.
>> You remember the Jerusalem council?
>> Yeah. where representatives elders from
all over the empire came together uh to
deal with the issue of circumcision.
They are also um they also deliberate
deliberate in council.
>> Mhm.
>> That's why the Jerusalem council was
called and finally they are administers
administrators of a section of the
church
>> right
>> of the global church. And so basically
the function of the elders on earth
>> is a model for the function of the
elders of heaven.
>> Right?
>> They have the same characteristics. But
the number 24 is to be taken as a
symbolic number of those who served the
needs of Israel. Um you also have the 70
elders.
>> Yes.
>> Who also represented Israel and uh and
they were members of God's council so to
speak. Uh so basically I would suggest
for more information uh to go to this uh
this study note that I prepared on the
24 elders. There's a lot of uh really
really important information in there.
Thank you, Pastor.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you so very much. 24,
a representative of spiritual governance
I have in my notes and we thank you for
your question and um yeah and in my in I
mean and the concept that pastor B
mentioned in regards to the 20 24 elders
or 24 being um a symbol of serving the
sanctuary that's actually found in the 1
Chronicles 24 chapter 24 that
>> you know describes how David divided uh
the the priests to serve the sanctuary
during the year 24 groups. So it's a
symbol again
>> and also if you go to Luke chapter one
the the Zecharias was served was serving
in the sanctuary in the eighth course.
>> Correct.
>> Correct. Part of the
>> So it shows that there were 24 courses
right and they were repeated twice a
year. Yes.
>> By by the priests.
>> Praise the Lord. You know again and we
we talked about this in a prior
broadcast.
This understanding of the sanctuary
enriches our walk with the Lord so very
very much and informs so much of what
what we do. uh because so much is based
upon that and uh any religious system
that has no understanding of the
sanctuary is really kind of impoverished
because it does enrich so very much what
we do what we say and it lets us know
where we are in history what's happening
on earth and in heaven and gives us
strong strong clues as to how it's going
to end when it's going to end and why
it's going to end so it's
>> if I could mention one more thing
>> and that is that God has a complex uh
organizational system that runs the
universe.
>> Um
by the way the Ellen White is a
quotation where it becomes very very
clear that there's not only 24 worlds.
Um this statement is found in review and
herald September 25 1900. She wrote God
has worlds upon worlds that are obedient
to his law. These worlds are conducted
with reference to the glory of the
creator.
>> As the inhabitants of these worlds see
the great price that he has paid to
ransom men, they are filled with
amazement. With intense interest, they
watch the controversy between Christ and
Satan. And as this controversy
progresses and the glory of God shines
brighter and brighter, they give praise
to God.
>> Uh now God has an organizational system
in heaven with different ranks.
>> Yeah. You know he you have Michael the
archangel, you have cherubim, you have
saraphim, you have el corn and white
commanding angels, strong angels, the
highest of angels. Yes.
>> Uh and that's reflected for example in
um in Colossians 1:16 where it speaks
about God's organizational system. For
by him all things were created that are
in heaven and that are on earth, visible
and invisible, whether thrones or
dominions or principalities or powers.
There you have the different ranks that
you have in the universe. As Satan has
kind of copied that
because it says in u in Ephesians 6:12,
for we do not wrestle against flesh and
blood, but against principalities,
against powers, against the rulers of
the darkness of this age. Satan also has
his counsel,
>> right?
>> Ellen White has statements where she
says that Satan before he takes any
steps, he consults with his with his
council members.
>> Yes. Uh so he's basically copied, you
know, uh the way that God runs uh the
heavenly universe. Um Ellen White um
wrote in Desire of Ages 8:34.
Um that when Jesus ascended to heaven,
these ranks already existed. And they're
not it's not speaking about humans
because at that point when Jesus went to
heaven, there were other than Moses and
Elijah, there were no humans up there.
She wrote with joy unable
rulers and principalities and powers
acknowledged the supre supremacy of the
prince of life.
>> So there were there to welcome Jesus um
rulers, principalities and powers
>> and powers.
>> You know God is not a dictator where he
sits on his throne and and does
everything.
>> Yeah. Now he he delegates responsib he
could do it all by himself,
>> but he delegates responsibility uh like
he you know could God finish the work a
a lot easier on on this earth without
us? Of course he could.
>> But he wants us to participate in his
government.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. And amen. All righty. Let's try to
squeeze this last question in. The
preamble to the question is is fairly
extensive. We'll try to work our way
through it. Dear Pastor Boore, my name
is Karen, originally from Malaysia, now
living in Western Australia. I have this
question that I can't fully understand
and hoping that you may give me your
advice. I had recently read the book
Early Writings. In the chapter about the
third angel's message, Mrs. White wrote
about William Miller. In page 257, she
wrote, "My attention was then called to
William Miller. I saw leading men
watching him and fearing less he should
receive the third angel's message and
the commandments of God. At length
William Miller raised his voice against
the light from heaven. He learned he
leaned rather to human wisdom instead of
divine. But being broken with arduous
labor in the master's cause and by age,
he was not as accountable as those who
kept him from the truth. They are
responsible. The sin rests upon them.
And she wrote, "God suffered him to fall
under the power of Satan, the dominion
of death, and hid him in the grave from
those who were constantly drawing him
from the truth. I saw that William
Miller aired as he was uh soon to enter
the heavenly Canaan. Others led him to
this. Others must account for it." But
angels watch the precious dust of this
servant of God, and he will come forth
at the sound of the last trumpet, the
last trump rather. All right, the
question, my question is, William Miller
obviously was given the third angel's
message, but he leaned to human wisdom
instead of divine. And Mrs. White
pointed out why he why is he not
accountable for his own decisions? Why
is that others led him to this? Others
must account for it. Why will he be
resurrected at Jesus second coming?
Isn't that Isn't that sound Doesn't that
sound like he is saved by his works?
Please don't get me wrong. Uh I am not
against William Miller being saved. I
just can't understand why he is not
judged by his own by the decisions he
made i.e. example uh to listen to men
instead of the divine. Do I miss
something here that I don't see? Looking
forward to your views on this.
Well, it's an interesting um uh
description and I'm glad that she uh has
this question because it's a question
that I think some individuals will also
connect with and resonate with. You
know, how is it possible that in a sense
William Miller who
uh obviously was part of the great
disappointment and did not see Jesus
Christ come in 1844?
Uh why is it that he when he was
presented with the light of the three
messages, why did he not uh accept it
and yet he's going to be saved? So I
guess that's in summary the question. Uh
I think that it's important to to look
at this question in using the example of
someone in the Bible which is in my
became to my mind the case of John the
Baptist. John the Baptist was one that
announced and prepared the way of the
Messiah of Jesus Christ. And he was
filled with the Holy Spirit. He he was
one that was uh you know instrumental in
making the the people be prepared to
receive Christ. However, as we know when
he got into jail when he because he was
preaching against Herod as he be got get
into the jail he was influenced by his
own disciples to start doubting the you
know the messiahship of Jesus. And he
sent that message of, you know, are you
the one we're expecting or are we
supposed to expect somebody else? Now,
the influence of those individuals had
caused John the Baptist to start
doubting and put in his mind the doubt
of who Jesus was. Now Jesus
um obviously uh
answered when they when he sent that
question he's he he showed the evidence
of his messianship and told those
disciples go tell him what you have seen
and in a sense that helped John the
Baptist realize that it was you know not
necessary for him to doubt Christ. It
was that that Christ had indeed been
fulfilled as the Messiah. But I say this
because in the concept of of of of John
the Baptist, he was a much younger
individual, not like William Miller. Uh
but he was you know taken to this doubt
by others influence and Christ uh did
not reject him but in a way tried to
prove him that he was indeed the
Messiah. In the case of William Miller,
he had understood so many of the
doctrines, so many of the prophecies. He
was fundamental, instrumental in in in
really presenting the second coming of
Christ. But because of his mistake and
because he got uh or because he was not
willing to or not able to see
everything, Christ did not reject him
necessarily based on the fact that he
was of old age as well mentions clearly
and because the influence of those
around him were strong enough to
persuade him to doubt this message as
being the light of God. He had already
gone through three uh disappointments in
a sense in his life and so he was more
hesitant to accept this truth and the
influence of these individuals really
pushed in his heart the idea that you
know it was not like to be received.
Christ considers everything and knows
the fair judgment. And in the case of
William Miller, he allowed him to go to
the grave and not be, you know, not not
be spared of grave, but he was to go to
the grave in an effort for him to put
him to rest. And at the end, he will
receive him as his elect. And I think
that is important to know that God is a
fair judge and he will judge according
to the light that we receive. And in the
case of Lula Miller, he's not
accountable because the influence of the
ones around him were fundamental in him
rejecting that light. It was not
necessarily that he was his own choice
per se. It was influenced by these
individuals. And because of his lack of
uh age or lack of strength or or or you
know, he's been old in age. I think that
is why God, as he always says, you know,
allowed him not to go to the brigade.
>> A couple things jump out at me. Um I
think your your use of uh John the
Baptist is well taken. Ellen White says
in Desire of Ages in trying to comfort
and encourage him his disciples only
>> make him worse.
>> Using my word she she they followed
things up. They made it worse you know
and and she says sometimes in our trying
to ameliate somebody's suffering we just
we just kind of make things worse.
>> Um
I believe that God uses people as much
as he can. Um Martin Luther was the
father of the reformation but at the end
of his life the back end he wrote some
anti-semitic things which will really
just kind of blow your mind. Um u
William Miller Ellen White says 720
sermons a year
>> for so many years he just burnt himself
out for the Lord. And there were those
who were trying to massage him. They
were trying to use him trying to push
him. I mean, after the first two
disappointments, Samuel Snow, who had
good intentions uh moved him into this
October 22nd date because he was not
hard on this date. He was around uh that
date. But again, there were people who
were trying and this is the thing,
Pastor Boris, you well know that men who
are given leadership positions have to
watch out for because sometimes there
are people surrounding you who may have
their own agendas or try to do other
things. So you need to surround yourself
with godly people who want the the
program of God to succeed and move in
that vein because where you who the
person that gets into your ears gets
into your head gets into your heart and
then you start moving that way. Uh and
we can see that through great men. Does
that negate the work that they did? No,
it does not. But sometimes we're all
human and we fall into these things.
Look at Hazen Foss. Look at William Foy
previous to Ellen G. White. You know,
there are men who God used as far as he
could take them, and he squeezed the
good out of them. Yeah. But were they
perfect? No, they were not.
>> I'm glad I'm not the judge.
>> Mhm.
>> God knew the heart of William Miller.
>> Amen.
>> We see what's before our eyes, but God
looks at the heart.
>> Um, we've never been through three
disappointments,
>> right,
>> concerning the second coming of Christ.
>> Yes.
We didn't preach 72 72 sermons. Was that
720?
>> 720 SE sermons a year.
>> We never were dashed in disappointment.
So let's God let God be God.
>> Amen.
>> Yes.
Well said.
>> Again, thank you for joining us. We'll
see you again soon. Bye-bye and God
bless.
Heat.
[Music]